really excited to see
ak in the grand finals right now ladies
and gentlemen sending jewels to the
losers bracket where he will wait
between the winner of rgn
versus mari
rgn versus maru uh gonna be another fun
one right we'll see what character mario
decides to give us this time uh so far
in this top eight we've seen both the
negan and the pakaram out of him uh so
we'll see which one decides to go with
here against the kuma i mean that is the
benefit right rgn you can pretty much
guarantee that that akuma is the one
that you're gonna be going up against so
you kind of have a choice when you have
multiple characters about which one you
want to fight a kumo with
yeah and that's we're gonna find that
real suit the
yeah the decision is right now so
we have
fakum ram versus akuma now quite frankly
this is okay for [ __ ] because he is a
big character he can catch the demon
flips
with no effort required so let's see
hmm
yeah this is i mean in america we don't
really have akuma players man uh we're
weird out of here we're in america we
don't like using the top yeah dude we
don't have any koopas like we have like
maybe one or two but they're not really
doing so hot uh so you know a matchup
like this you would think that we would
have seen by now but this is something
that i rarely ever get to see [ __ ]
wrong versus akuma
let me see how he has can he just jab
out the demon flip
with his head we'll see about that we're
gonna find out with his
[Laughter]
no proper punish and rgn gets the
perfect punish in 13 frames maru good
punishable so here we go
what the what
oh what do you think we're gonna come
out and start
very weird how do we start here
hey hey
patience kick goes with the low mix this
time
you know throughout the loser bracket
and [ __ ] around we've seen the mid mix
come out every time that was one of the
first times he's done the low
okay
are playing it a bit slow right now rgn
running one
oh the thunder god kick maru falls over
the combo we're not going to see a wall
but [ __ ] mom's wall carry is crazy
good
what the hell yeah [ __ ] around pretty
good
see always duck always down back
you heard it here folks duck always
after they drop the fadc combo
prepare for the drops
as much as you can
don't give them faith it's not even
disrespectful it's respecting how
difficult their combos are you know like
oh wow this is really difficult you may
drop that you know
oh here we go oh no he dropped the combo
again rick what have you done
this i dude it's been like this all
night i haven't done
it mario two runs now rgn looking for
more openings here oh that could have
been his opportunity but he missed it
uh-oh one two one four rgn plus nine
they using big
enrage
oh my goodness that could have been it
but rgn gets him with a counter his
double jab into the fabc combo but the
downside of that is he doesn't have the
meter anymore
that's very true here no mirror to work
with
but mario's so patient he gets akuma
right it looks like he has a lot of
experience against his character
oh look out
that's not what you want though
yeah this is exactly wall carries
[Music]
yeah he knew he needed to spend that bar
and he built the meter during the combo
itself that was really smartly played by
rgn but here we go final round game one
only best of three here
good block a block and punished by rgn
now maru's one hit away from getting
rage rgn is sitting so comfortably with
this life lead maru's in big trouble one
more hit could do it gets the whip
takes game one against maru who's
looking so good in the first two rounds
that was a beautiful comeback right and
he was it looked like he was falling
apart a little bit right and the the
game started off a little bit shaky on
both sides uh but rgn once he put the
pieces together you know once he
recomposed himself uh you know when i
said put the pieces again i mean put
himself back together uh and recompose
himself you know things really came
together the whiff punch at the end was
fantastic the combo started coming
together uh you know and that was just
really smartly played and i think i
think mario got a little ahead of
himself i feel like he thought he
already had that game closed out but it
wasn't closed out it's never over until
it's over that's how the saying goes and
it's that for a reason uh very nice
comeback there from rgn
and that's always a factor right when
you're about to close the game out you
gotta stay on your feet you gotta
you gotta play the game that he always
used to not not be you know not be hasty
you gotta slow it down know that it's
not over just yet and there's still
chance for your opponent to come back
from this that's uh that's the mental
game right there that's also coming into
play when you're in a match so
yeah so that that might have been the
case might have been the case for maru
but let's see if we'll see a uh
character switch here
yeah i mean that's a that's a great
question i mean what are the characters
does he have other than the negan
he might i mean i'm i'm not banging on
it but he might but you know
[ __ ] it stick it out all day every day
yeah
all day early
focus gonna be the character choice to
see
if maru can stay in the tournament here
only first two games are gin up 1-0 in
the set of course
uh this time we're going to abandon
temple so he's giving him his own stage
he's like you know what this is your
stage right akuma i'm gonna beat you on
your own stage round one
uh let's see if that's gonna be the case
because rgn's been on its hair right now
maru
gotta find some opportunities they can
have that he can use for himself
okay now arjun's just standing around
he's just letting maru do whatever
he was waiting for an omnivore jumping
it looked like and he found what he
wanted
big likely you're still jumping at him
now god oh my god delayed hop kick from
[ __ ] rob
all right maru
all right
sidestep by maru so good and rgn does
have access to rage he gets him with a
while standing too but doesn't get the
whole combo in 20 seconds left what's
the mix up going to be goes for the grab
kill
oh my goodness oh my god he did the high
seconds left
oh my god
the iframes weren't there not in favor
of rgn and maru with round one
you didn't have metered ex that dp and
maru does get the round because of it
beautiful conversion now he's gonna
follow up with the full cobble rgn is he
gonna get away from this wall the next
the dp
what's he gonna do
holy moly that was far better not lose
this life lead
dude we're all caught up one combo here
and it could be rj's round but the teep
kick
gonna keep things in maru's favor two
rounds now
uh-huh
oh that was scary he could have gotten
full combo right there but rgn gets him
instead with the demon flip mix-up
and maru
receiving a lot of damage here big boy
privileges
rga oh the
[Music]
yeah big trouble but he's got our gems
back the wall got to watch out for that
extp you know the rj's willing to throw
it out
beautiful stop them
wow you stop it stop that momentum right
there i don't like it
now
pay attention he does have the meter
here ladies and gentlemen be careful
maru or he's gonna get full combo in
this case rgn presses on that last hit
maru has to close this one out rgn has
momentum
yeah but he's way behind in life right
now
doesn't spend any meter here doesn't
have rage at either now he's got a rage
now it can hurt he drops the combo he
dropped it but still in it
doesn't have a meter almost the next
part he's got the bar now
one more hit
to finish it out rg and builds up a
meter and takes it to a potential final
round can maru take it to a game three
or will rgn pull an upset he's got the
combo this time here we go walk here
he's good
easy wall carry combo here what the mix
doesn't get the bounce caught him
airborne fire into the delayed hopkins
punish that big time
sidewall saves his life though rg and dp
maru outside of rage one more hit one
more combo from maru and he could be
done for rgn playing a bit more safely
plus nine rgn gotta get a delay hopkins
it's so dangerous yeah it's got you know
it's coming you know it's coming he
wants one he needs one
there's a bar of meter here and what can
he do with is he even gonna use it maru
is just maintaining his distance he
doesn't want to go up in your face
there it
rgn catches him on the approach with the
down three fadc combo and eliminates
maru from tekken online challenge 2021
and moves on to the loser's final
that was so impressive both games there
maru had a two to zero round count lead
and arjun brought it back both times
very impressive stuff rgn moving in to
the top three here tonight very well
played
oh my god i'm gonna need to count i need
to take a breather off of that because i
i was crazy dude my goodness me